1v1
kelly against pasha the two players
who've stepped up phenomenally for their
side
i can't believe what i'm witnessing
right here wow get out of here
i think i was the first one to be kinda
realistic like are you shaking
cheating or not seven years ago cs go
almost
exploded um as several professional cs
go players have been
banned for cheating the bands come just
ahead of the dreamhack winter gaming
festival where the band players were
scheduled to compete in the cs go
championship for a 250
000 prize pool a cheating scandal rocked
the cs go community
and to this day people are still
scratching their heads
in which tournament it is [ __ ] and in
which ones he didn't
did callie cheat on a land why
and how did cs go survive its most
dangerous cheating scandal
ever what the [ __ ] he was playing titan
what the
he took my place he's cheating
him
all right folks before we get into
csgo's most insane cheating scandal ever
and whether or not callie actually
cheated on a lan
i want to make sure you're all sub to
the channel so please hit the subscribe
button and turn on notifications it
really does help a lot
in 2014 there was a moment where cs go
could have gone away completely a single
moment in time where
if anything went even a little bit
differently csgo might not have become
the
juggernaut that it is today csgo's
biggest
cheating scandal but before we can
explain exactly how this all went down
we need to talk a little bit about what
cs go was like in 2014
before the vacuning cs go was barely two
years old
fresh off of a terrible launch that
basically everyone hated
dota's ti was already pulling in
multi-million dollar prize pools and the
league of legends world championship
sold out the staple center meanwhile
while cs's majors were hype
they were still basically just really
fancy lan parties
but the future seemed bright for cs go
and going into the dreamhack winter 2014
major
all eyes were on titan the french cs go
scene just went through a big roster
shuffle and a bunch of ldlc players
moved over to titan
those players just top aided the clone
major giving titan a guaranteed spot at
dreamhack vertus pros
might be done here he has nothing
congratulations
what a player what a team and what a
phenomenal display from lvlc
vertus pro just couldn't do it and ltlc
congratulations well done ldlc the team
was stacked with
some of the best talent that cs go had
to offer but for our purposes
the most important person on the team
was callie
and uh any moment now mbk will run right
into his crosshairs but we'll be fast
enough take him out yes he will he will
finish him off and he's gonna go for a
second he's gonna get that second
apex and a third enough out of school
fourth as well and cooley is still going
to work some ground in the middle
oh and the third what is going on okay
he's just going insane in this
game oh my god he gets taken down but my
god kaley going massive like i said
callie helped ldlc make it to the semis
at a major
and now titan were among the favorites
to take the next one
and even if he was not playing good in
practice individually we were so good
as a team and
so we we knew that we would do something
good at the tournament
a few months before the major titan
dummied fnatic
ldlc and nip three of the best teams in
the world
at the dreamhack invitational in
stockholm 30 seconds is not a lot of
time right now for real dlc they got to
get into this bomb site quickly
and see if they can avoid losing anyone
apex turning around and
perfect timing shots he's gone and now
ldlc are in a very deep hole here
kiyoshima
and smith they have the equipment to buy
their way out of this one apex will take
a headshot now smith in a one-on-three
and this is the tournament life here for
ldlc he picks up walmart kaylee ends it
and titan win remax.com
right here titan were on fire and cali
was a hot up-and-comer in the
international scene
but then everything went wrong
and everyone set up you know it's a
keyboard mode etc and
uh he got that by insta when he joined
the server
i think i was the first one to be kinda
realistic like are you shaking
cheating or not and he was like no no no
and apex was you know like uh shouting
on a boy
you have to trust him of course he's not
cheating on november 20th 2014
just nine days before the major cali was
hit with a vac van out of
nowhere
[Music]
i don't trust that cersei can you call
it the news was
genuinely unbelievable a top cs go
player someone who had played on
lan at a major no less was banned for
cheating
now cs go is a remarkably easy game to
cheat in
sure valve's anti-cheat software has
gotten a lot better over the years but
anybody who's played even a minute of
matchmaking knows just how many cheaters
are polluting the servers
are you kidding me
that's new but cheating on a land
without getting caught
is hard and cheating at all is the
number one
absolute cardinal sin of esports
it's like when an athlete takes steroids
if you find out the best players in the
world
aren't actually that good at the game
why would you ever
watch it's just simple on his own lone
wolf
with the awp he's out in the russian
wilderness just sniping
did emilio just get back banned all this
is to say that
kelly getting banned was a huge deal and
cali wasn't the only person banned
several high-profile players got hit
with the same sudden vac bans that same
week
all of whom were found to be cheating as
lioness noted in this old ncix news
video
um as several professional cs go players
have been banned for cheating
including simon smn beck
and gordon s f jeri it's sort of
impossible to overstate just how big a
deal this whole scandal was
so many players got banned and callie
was about to play in the major
did he actually cheat did he do it on a
lan
and if he was cheating how many other
tier 1 players were doing the same
thing the next day cali posted on
facebook
admitting that out of curiosity he had
used some cheating software while
playing matchmaking back in august
a few hours later titan kicked him off
the team but the damage was
already done as a result titan lost
their spot at the major
something that stung pretty bad for
cali's now ex-teammates
if it was another timing maybe it would
be no problem but
what was really
like uh frustrated
like we were so [ __ ] in shape at this
moment we were practicing
like we were so good in practice but the
bigger question
was whether or not kelly ever cheated on
a lan see while cali
said that he'd only ever cheated in
matchmaking some people
doubted that there's like a video that
surfaced of him like
aimbotting like in one of the very early
go tournaments like
like i'm talking like really early 2013
when go first came out
and he was just blatantly aimbotting so
he did cheat online for sure at one
point
there were a couple of questionable
plays but people obsessed over one in
particular
a jumping pistol headshot from esl one
cologne 2014.
don't tell me you can do it he gets the
tag he's not going for it there we go
pasha
1v1 kelly against pascha the two
players who've stepped up phenomenally
for their side
i can't believe what i'm witnessing
right here wow get out of here
you get can you believe it to secure the
final kill
it needs something special from these
guys and that is it
the shot is nuts but unfortunately for
all the amateur reddit detectives out
there
it's not actually totally impossible at
least that's what youtuber 3 clicks
phillips found when he attempted it 100
times
i made it 14 head and 12 shots hitting
elsewhere making the outcome look like
this
so what's the shot lucky yes but not as
unlikely as you might think the chances
of hitting it are around 25 percent at
best before you factor in things like
how
charlie may not have fired at the top of
his jump or know where pasha was
standing before jumping
i think there is some tournaments where
i didn't cheat
[Music]
but i am sure he cheated in some
tournament also because
you know i could see it in his eyes you
know when we ask him
are you cheating or not you know he was
not precise so
of course he he cheated in some
tournaments but i don't think you
cheated all the time
and then of course there was the last
question
was anyone else cheating callie's band
threw the cheating accusations against
prose into overdrive
suddenly it seemed like everyone was a
cheater hell calling people out was so
common that
hiko even relayed his teammates
accusations in a post-game interview
with the sca
i know that a couple of my teammates are
convinced that
they think they cheat in the months and
years following cali's ban
no one was saved from cheating
accusations which caused a lot of
problems for up-and-coming young players
who are trying to make a name for
themselves online
they wanted to know if i was it was
really that talented and they started
calling me a cheater at one point
for me the biggest thing with stewie2k
is
he does he does this thing now okay he
never used to do this
he never used to do this uh apparently
it's only started happening
since he's been playing for cloud nine
and uh he does this thing with his mouse
despite that major having its own messy
controversy in the form of the infamous
olaf boost
dreamhack winner 2014 went off without a
hitch and just a few months later at esl
one cudavite
cs go broke one million concurrent
viewers on twitch for the first time
ever oh there it is now it's on exist
1v2 here fanatic
they could be the second or the first
team to win a second championship here
on global offensive and olofmeisters
playing it so safely
they know that they have it exists gets
one and he's back on it he's got the kid
he's holding it down i'm not sure
there's enough time
fanatic
ladies and gentlemen your esl one
camelita champions are fanatic
cs go survive the cheating scandal
because
well because the game is just that good
by late 2016 esea and faceit released
better anti-cheat software while
increasingly rigorous hardware checks
became standard at lan
and after a while it became clear that
cheating at a major land without getting
caught was
basically impossible can this guy as
many times as he's done
go up in front of not only a giant
[ __ ] crowd and stadium
but hundreds of thousands of people
online and
the and play and compete against these
people that hurt his real life friends
for years and years and years
and cheat them out of hundreds of
thousands of dollars multiple times over
again
and you have you get to get out of here
dude
you can't do that so what happened to
the rest of the people who were caught
up in the scandal well the rest of the
titan members
kinda got screwed they just edged their
weight out of the smoke
kenny in the smoke though doesn't really
find much luck
maniac goes down rpk a1 versus five
touches all that can save the now and
it's not gonna happen
16 to four penta
absolute domination titans struggled
bombing out of the next major they could
play in before eventually
falling apart in 2016 the org folded
citing the cali scandal as one of the
big reasons why they just couldn't keep
going
as for the players themselves they all
went on to do bigger and better things
on other french cs go teams
and kenny s and apex even won a major in
2015.
oh and a second headshot there flamie
gonna be gone hiroshima and there it is
winning the last major of 2015 and the
second title in aurora
ever for three of these players the
first to penny and apex
what a victory and as for cali
well he tried to make a return to cs go
in 2017 but
things didn't exactly work out a lot of
people just
didn't want to play with him and the
fact that he couldn't play in a major
because of his vacman meant that any
team that wanted to play in real events
was
never gonna sign him and his name kind
of became a meme
brought up whenever anyone made a play
that just kind of looked impossible
okay quickly activated my friend
yeah cookie style activated activated i
can see the okay if i can see this guy
oh my god
since then cali turned to streaming and
eventually opened up a luxury car rental
service in l.a
weird i know and at least one of kelly's
former teammates
isn't nearly as mad at him anymore i
have
maybe not too much problem with him like
of course what he did was bad was bad
for every one of
us but it was like especially bad for
himself so actually i feel
more bad for him that for us so
yeah i could speak with him in real life
i think
these days it's hard to imagine that one
cheating scandal could completely upend
cs go
in fact we've had plenty since from
eibach power's match fixing scandal that
broke in 2015
to forsaken cheating on elaine in 2018
to the coaching bug mess in 2020
cs go is riddled with scandal but it
refuses
to die that moment in time when cali
cheated the vaccining happened and
everyone questioned the legitimacy of
pro cs go is
long gone the cs go community still
wears those scars but
it wears them with pride it wears them
knowing that it survived a
game destroying scandal at its most
vulnerable moment
and kept going and it survived to become
one of the biggest esports
in the world cali's been through the
cheating
detectives reddit detectives
oh red detectives i see what you're
saying should play phoenix writers
detective called dick gumshoe
in the french version his name is
detective
yes
because well i think the pun in japanese
is very similar to like dick gumshoe
that his name is two
like slaying terms for a detective
his name is dick gumshoe so he's
detective detective
it's pretty good it's pretty good it's
not a good herlock shoalms but
they can't all be bangers